Hace casi 30 años,
mi país se enfrentó a la necesidad de reconstruir todo desde sus cimientos.
Tras años de ocupación soviética,
Estonia recuperó su independencia, pero nos dejaron sin nada.
Sin infraestructura, sin administración, sin código legal.
Un caos organizativo.
Por necesidad,
los líderes de estado de aquel entonces tomaron algunas decisiones atrevidas,
las que nuestro país pudiera permitirse.
Hubo mucha experimentación e incertidumbre,
pero también un poco de suerte,
sobre todo, porque contábamos con un gran número
de brillantes visionarios, criptógrafos e ingenieros.
Era una niña por aquel entonces.
Hoy, nos consideran la sociedad más digital de la Tierra.
Soy de Estonia,
y hemos estado declarando impuestos en línea desde 2001.
Hemos estado utilizando identificaciones y firmas digitales desde 2002.
Hemos estado votando en línea desde 2005.
Y a día de hoy, prácticamente todo el rango de servicios públicos
que puedan imaginar, educación, seguridad, justicia, comenzar una empresa,
solicitar prestaciones, revisar tu registro sanitario
o apelar en caso de multas de estacionamiento,
todo eso se hace en línea.
De hecho, es mucho más fácil decirles
qué tres cosas no podemos hacer aún en línea.
Tenemos que ir en persona a recoger nuestro documento de identificación,
casarnos o divorciarnos, o vender bienes inmuebles.
Eso es todo prácticamente.
Y por eso puedo afirmar —no se sorprendan—
que cada año no puedo esperar a hacer mi declaración de impuestos.
(Risas)
Porque todo lo que tengo que hacer es sentarme en mi sofá con mi móvil,
pasar unas pocas páginas con datos ya rellenados sobre ingresos y deducciones
y presionar "enviar".
A los tres minutos estaré mirando mi declaración de impuestos.
La verdad es que es una experiencia gratificante.
Sin asesor fiscal, sin recolectar recibos,
sin realizar cálculos.
Y ¿he mencionado que no he visitado una oficina estatal en casi siete años?
De hecho, una de las características de la vida moderna
que ya no tiene razón de ser,
considerando las posibilidades tecnológicas actuales,
es el laberinto de la burocracia.
Nos hemos librado casi por completo de él en Estonia
gracias al esfuerzo coordinado del gobierno, que también se ha digitalizado.
El trabajo del gabinete de ministros en e-Cabinet carece de papeles por completo.
La idea central detrás de este desarrollo
es la transformación del rol del estado y la digitalización de la confianza.
Piénsenlo.
En la mayoría de los países, la gente no confía en su gobierno.
Y los gobiernos no confían en ellos.
Todos los complicados procesos formales basados en papeles
se supone que resolverían ese problema.
Pero no lo hacen.
Tan solo hacen la vida más complicada.
Creo que la experiencia en Estonia muestra que la tecnología puede ser el remedio
para recuperar esa confianza al mismo tiempo que se crea
un sistema de envío eficiente y centrado en el usuario
que responda de forma activa a las necesidades de los ciudadanos.
No lo conseguimos al digitalizar la burocracia en sí,
sino al llegar a un acuerdo acerca de algunos puntos fuertes y comunes,
alterando las leyes y procedimientos,
deshaciéndonos de recolecciones de datos innecesarias
y de la duplicación de tareas,
volviéndonos abiertos y transparentes.
Déjenme mostrarles
algunos de los principios de diseño clave de e-Estonia.
Lo primero es garantizar la privacidad y confidencialidad
de los datos y la información.
Esto se consigue a través de una fuerte identificación digital
otorgada por el estado y compatible con todo.
De hecho, cada estonio tiene una.
La identificación se refuerza con una fuerte firma digital
que es aceptada, utilizada y jurídicamente vinculante
tanto en Estonia como en la Unión Europea.
Cuando el sistema identifique de forma adecuada y segura quién lo está usando,
tras iniciar sesión, proporcionará acceso a los datos personales del ciudadano
y a todos los servicios públicos en una única herramienta.
Esto permite autorizar cualquier procedimiento mediante la firma digital.
El segundo principio, uno de los más transformadores,
se llama "Solo una vez".
Quiere decir que el estado no puede pedir los mismos datos más de una vez,
ni puede guardarlos en más de un lugar.
Por ejemplo,
si ya han llevado su certificado de nacimiento o estado civil
al registro civil,
ese será el único lugar donde dichos datos serán almacenados.
Y ninguna otra institución volverá a pedirlos.
"Solo una vez" es una regla muy poderosa,
ya que define la estructura completa de la recolección de datos de un país:
qué información se recopila y quién es responsable de mantenerla.
Así nos aseguramos de evitar la centralización de los datos,
la duplicación de los datos,
y de garantizar que estén actualizados.
Esta aproximación por distribución
también evita el problema del punto único de fallo.
Como los datos no pueden replicarse ni recolectarse más de una vez,
el diseño del sistema deberá tener en cuenta
un acceso seguro y robusto a esa información en todo momento
para que la institución pública pueda ofrecer un servicio.
Este es exactamente el papel que tiene la plataforma de intercambio de datos
llamada X-Road, que ha sido utilizada desde 2001.
Al igual que una autopista,
conecta las bases de datos y registros del sector público,
municipios locales y empresas,
organizando un intercambio de datos en tiempo real, seguro y regulado,
dejando un rastro verificable tras cada movimiento.
Aquí tienen una captura de pantalla de una transmisión en vivo
que muestra todas las peticiones realizadas en X-Road
y todos los servicios que facilita.
Y esta es la imagen real
de todas las conexiones entre bases de datos de los sectores público y privado.
Como pueden ver, no hay base de datos central.
La confidencialidad y la privacidad son muy importantes.
Pero en el mundo digital,
la fiabilidad e integridad de la información
son críticas para las operaciones.
Por ejemplo, si alguien altera su registro sanitario de salud,
como sus alergias, sin que Uds. ni sus médicos se den cuenta,
el tratamiento podría ser mortal.
Por eso en la sociedad digital, un sistema como el estonio,
donde apenas hay copias originales en papel,
y prácticamente solo copias originales digitales,
la integridad de los datos,
las reglas de intercambio de datos, los componentes de los programas
y los archivos de registro son primordiales.
Utilizamos un tipo de cadena de bloques que inventamos allá en 2007,
antes de que las cadenas de bloques fuesen conocidas,
para comprobar y garantizar la integridad de los datos en tiempo real.
La cadena de bloques es nuestro auditor y asegura que ningún acceso a los datos
o manipulación de datos quede sin ser registrada.
La propiedad de datos es otro principio clave en el diseño del sistema.
¿No temen que los gobiernos, las empresas tecnológicas
y otras empresas alrededor del mundo
reclamen que datos recolectados sobre Uds. son suyos,
generalmente negando a otros acceder a esa información
y a menudo no pueden demostrar cómo se usó
o compartió con terceras personas?
No sé, a mí me parece una situación muy inquietante.
El sistema estonio se basa en el principio
de que el individuo es el propietario de los datos recopilados sobre él,
y por ello tiene derecho absoluto a conocer qué información se recopila
y quién accede a ella.
Cada vez que un policía, médico o cualquier oficial del estado
accede a información personal de los ciudadanos en línea,
lo primero es que solo consiguen acceso tras iniciar sesión
a la información que están autorizados a ver para hacer su trabajo.
Y lo segundo es que cada vez que hacen una petición,
esta se guarda en archivos de registro.
Este archivo de registro detallado es parte de los servicios públicos estatales
y permite transparencia real,
asegurando que toda violación de privacidad sea notificada al ciudadano.
Ahora bien, esto es solo un resumen simplificado
de todos los principios de diseño sobre los que se construye e-Estonia.
Y ahora, el gobierno está preparándose
para usar la inteligencia artificial
y para poder construir una nueva generación de servicios públicos,
servicios proactivos que se activarían de forma impecable
basándose en diferentes situaciones en las que pueda encontrarse alguien,
como el nacimiento, el desempleo o la fundación de una empresa.
Por supuesto que llevar una sociedad digital sin copias de respaldo en papel
puede ser un problema, ¿verdad?
Incluso aunque confiemos en que nuestros sistemas son sólidos,
uno nunca es lo suficientemente cauteloso, como experimentamos en 2007,
cuando el primer ciberincidente tuvo lugar
y literalmente bloqueó parte de nuestras redes,
imposibilitando el acceso a los servicios durante horas.
Sobrevivimos.
Pero este suceso puso a la ciberseguridad en lo más alto de la agenda,
tanto en cuestión de fortalecer la plataforma como de respaldarla.
¿Cómo respaldan un sistema que abarca todo un país en un pequeño estado
donde todo está muy próximo entre sí?
Bueno, pueden exportar una copia de los datos
fuera del territorio del país hacia una embajada extraterritorial.
Hoy en día, tenemos estas embajadas de datos
que guardan los activos digitales más cruciales de Estonia,
y garantizan la continuidad de las operaciones,
la protección de nuestros datos y, sobre todo, nuestra soberanía,
incluso si se diese un ataque físico en nuestro territorio.
Alguno de Uds. puede estar pensando: "¿Cuál es el lado negativo?".
Mientras que digitalizarlo todo
es administrativamente y, seamos honestos, económicamente más eficiente,
interactuar sobre todo con computadoras
puede causar la impresión de que el factor humano,
la elección de políticos
y la participación en procesos democráticos
es, de alguna forma, menos importante.
Y también hay personas
que se sienten amenazadas por la dominancia tecnológica
que pueda hacer que sus habilidades se vuelvan obsoletas.
Así que, desafortunadamente,
organizar un país en una plataforma digital
no nos ha salvado de las luchas políticas por el poder
y la polarización de la sociedad,
como hemos visto en las últimas elecciones.
Bueno, mientras haya personas involucradas...
Una última pregunta.
Si todo es independiente de localización
y puedo acceder a todos los servicios desde cualquier parte del mundo,
¿por qué otros no pueden acceder a algunos de estos servicios
aunque no vivan dentro de Estonia?
Hace cinco años
iniciamos una propuesta gubernamental llamada "programa e-Residency"
que hoy en día reúne a decenas de miles de personas.
Se trata de empresarios y empresarias de 136 países diferentes
que establecen sus negocios digitalmente,
que hacen sus gestiones bancarias en línea
y que dirigen sus compañías virtualmente en la plataforma e-Estonia,
dentro del marco legal de la Unión Europea,
utilizando una tarjeta de e-identificación similar a la mía
y todo eso desde cualquier parte del mundo.
El sistema estonio es independiente de localización
y está centrado en el usuario.
Prioriza la inclusión, transparencia y fiabilidad.
Se centra en la seguridad y la transparencia.
Y pone los datos en las manos de su legítimo propietario,
la persona a la que hacen referencia.
No se conformen con mis palabras.
Pruébenlo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)